[Musique]
chers compatriotes
honnêtement vous sentez vous plus en
sécurité aujourd'hui qu'en dvd
bien sûr que non les événements du 27
mars à paris gare du nord illustre
l'échec de monsieur sarkozy ministre de
l'intérieur pendant plus de quatre ans
al'inverse de ce qu'il prétend grâce à
des statistiques truquées
son bilan est accablant il n'y a pas eu
trois millions sept cent mille crimes et
délits en 2006 comme ils l'affirment
mais 12 millions 400 mille selon
l'observatoire national de la
délinquance qu'il a lui-même mis en
place monsieur ment avec aplomb comment
oublier les quarante cinq mille voitures
brûlées chaque année la multiplication
des violences aux personnes et des
agressions gratuites les premières
victimes sont nos compatriotes les plus
vulnérables les femmes les enfants les
personnes âgées et aussi ceux qui
habitent dans les zones de non droit
monsieur sarkozy a échoué parce qu'il a
poursuivi la politique de ses
prédécesseurs socialistes d'abord la
police qui est tenu en suspicion n'est
pas autorisée à réprimer les émeutiers
qui agissent donc en toute impunité
ensuite l'immigration augmente au rythme
de quatre cent cinquante mille entrées
annuelles
c'est une des causes principales de la
sécurité puisque selon la direction
centrale de la sécurité publique 60 à
70% des délinquants sont d'origine
immigrée enfin en supprimant la
prétendue double peine nicolas sarkozy a
permis nos délinquants étrangers comme
le fraudeur de la gare du nord par
exemple de rester en france pour moi une
chose est sûre pour un étranger résider
sur le territoire français c'est un
privilège qui n'est ouvert qu'aux
honnêtes gens la sécurité est la
première des libertés pour la rétablir
je redonnerai aux forces de l'ordre les
moyens de remplir leur mission
toutes les infractions seront réellement
sanctionnés par des peines pour
certaines et incompressibles pour les
crimes les plus graves
la peine capitale sera rétabli la
justice aujourd'hui parent pauvre de
l'etat sera renforcée
et son impartialité assuré je veillerai
à ce que les puissants notamment les
dirigeants politiques soit quand ils ont
commis un délit sanctionné au moins
aussi sévèrement que ne le sont les
simples citoyens
quelle peine peut-on infliger un voleur
de scooter quand un ministre qui a volé
des millions contribuable risque juste
un an avec sursis
par ailleurs il est urgent de moderniser
et d'humaniser notre système
pénitentiaire par un grand programme de
construction de 100 mille places de
prison en cinq ans à plus long terme le
rétablissement de la sécurité nécessite
la remise en ordre des institutions qui
assuraient l'encadrement intellectuel et
moral de notre société que les vieilles
idéologies soixante huitarde ont voulu
détruire
je parle bien sûr de la famille et de
l'école premier cadre de transition des
règles de la vie en collectivité
première cellule de l'éducation civique
et morale des jeunes
la sécurité elle commence bien sûr avec
l'apprentissage du respect de l'autorité
familiale scolaire judiciaire et
institutionnels cette politique
cependant serait vaine si la sécurité
internationale de notre pays n'était pas
assurée l'esta tragique des libanais
hier du kosovo aujourd'hui illustre la
nécessité pour chaque peuple d'avoir les
moyens de défendre son indépendance
ces moyens là la france est en train de
les perdre
le budget de la défense qui représentait
2 6% de notre produit intérieur brut en
95 est tombé à 2 % après avoir supprimé
le service national monsieur chirac a
créé une armée n'ont pas de métier mais
de moitié puisque ses effectifs ont été
divisés par deux faute de crédits
nos matériels de guerre sont de moins en
moins adapté et depuis notre
réintégration dans l'otan nous avons
perdu notre indépendance militaire
chers compatriotes ne croyez pas les
démagogues
si vous disent que nous pouvons compter
sur l'eau est nu sur l'otan'' sur
l'union européenne pour nous protéger
la france puissance européenne et
maritime
du conseil de sécurité des nations unies
doit assurer elle même sa défense pour
renouer l'indispensable lien entre
l'armée et la nation
je propose la création d'un service
militaire volontaire de six mois
assortie d'un droit d'accès prioritaire
à la fonction publique
les volontaires pourront aussi s'ils le
veulent servir soit dans l'armée active
soit dans une garde nationale chargée de
la défense opérationnelle du territoire
assurer la sécurité des personnes et la
défense du territoire est la première
mission du chef de l'état chef des
armées
cette mission si vous m'accordez votre
confiance je la remplirai avec fermeté
et justice sans vacarme sans tapage mais
sans crainte
[Musique]